hey Guardians here to give you a quick
update on the Queen's wrath event
currently live on the Destiny servers
the event brought with it a new set of
bounties for you to complete Queens
wrath missions as well as a new MPC pet
revenge the Queen's emissary she sells
legendary shaders emblems a class armor
and some rare weapons will be
interesting to see if her inventory
changes when you hit level 3 in the
Queen's wrath reputation as her current
stock of items seems lacking the key
thing to note here is that by completing
a queen's wrath bounty you'll not only
earn queen's favor but you will also
unlock a queen's wrath mission you will
notice this in both your inventory under
the missions area as well as on the
orbit map on the left hand side the
Queen's wrath mission will always have
the modifier epic which makes for
heavily shielded and highly aggressive
enemies to appear in great numbers as
well as two other modifiers that are
mission-specific once you've launched
the Queen's wrath mission it will then
select a random mission from the game
for you to complete I personally came
across 526 various missions such as the
mission to defeat traxxas winter quell
the mission to retrieve a gate Lords
head stopping the shrine Oryx and even
one of the very first missions to
retrieve a warp drive for your ship in
the Cosmodrome the mission to retrieve
the warp drive is by far the easiest
quest within the ones that I was given
this mission only requires you to deal
with a small handful of enemies and a
boss who is relatively easy and does not
have any big threatening damage make
sure to target the shanks first because
I have heavy shielding they do however
fall from to proper shots from receber
rifle after defeating the boss with just
a few well-placed tempor shots to the
head finish some mission and receive
your Queens wrath legendary gear the
best way to take advantage of the
current system is to make sure you get
the mission to retrieve the warp drive
you can do this by restarting the
Queen's wrath mission over and over
until you get the mission to retrieve
the warp drive currently there is no
punishment for abandoning the missions
to start a new one this is the easiest
and fastest way to get some of the new
Queens wrath legendary gear and is also
a good way to farm ascendant shards to
upgrade your existing legendary and
exotic armors
you